welcome to this video this is canto
wrist as my opponent it seems out late
in before me either recall that handle
that don't really the games okay the
Vienna variation I'm trying this funky
gambit they're mostly because I don't
know any any mainline there and it is
quite dangerous that much is clear from
the current um tournament practice
Quincy form is coming with quite a
dangerous initiative
that's all I know really only that go
into G form and then try to use the good
piece play let's not spend lots of time
in
look you one not sure I've f4 as a move
there I think I rather want one to have
root III and quick quick quick rook
lifts night a fire that's a good try to
defend here definitely let's see that I
cannot take on anything if I go look III
night f5 hook h3 this looks this looks
really strange getting this rook there
to h6
okay so let's reroute here I think that
makes sense if he goes night at five i'm
going back to see one and then the ideas
queen h3 and g4
yeah I guess don't know if other squares
give me any benefit f4 not sure ok so
Queen h3 was my my idea for this g-form
push and let's do that that's a very
very hard position to play for both
sides I guess now think g6g six looks
right to me
okay I'm so after G for what is he doing
sacrificing the piece I guess yeah sure
thats it's possible who is not
sacrificing anything he just says you
have miscalculated maybe f ing five g5
immediately it's not working cheeks
five I wonder if I can take here maybe
taking cream cakes rookie for then g5 if
it takes if he takes with the Queen
which is not clear that he does
2g5 next is it's is dangerous I mean
really g5 our Bishop chicks
now that that should be if there should
be something here for wide okay start
with that more if that's not right I
don't know what so this move and now
what do i what am I going to do now if I
check he takes with the queen with check
look h4h form
what is the right continuation in this
position has sometimes it would be great
to be a good attacking player
I'm totally totally not sure he takes it
93 can take their I was thinking this
for Bishop age 7 and possibly Knight f3
Queen f6 I have some interesting moves
nyjah for for example
time warning ok didn't see that one
coming of course so him yeah but I've
just blundering this rook check this
rook is hanging wow what a bad session
yet this is something where you you know
when you look at this afterwards with
the engine you will just start to cry
because it will show you how you could
have played and if if there wasn't
something for Wyatt then I don't know
okay come on white resigns let's let's
let's see this I mean this sucky
absolutely I cannot believe this and the
computer says it's okay for like there
is no fairness in this world everything
is on his King night both bishops the
rook only four and there is no wind down
okay at least then I cannot be blamed
for not finding it I mean what I played
was a joke but I really thought there
must be some kind of way here to get
this attack to something computer seized
absolutely nothing it's always f5 and
push of a three f 5 and this is a huge
move of course maybe it's it's around
here that I have to have to improve
I know it's two pawns but they're still
quite quite some pressure comes up with
this movement and says it's equal equal
as a cool evaluation 22 points down
there he played that yeah this is this
is what I wanted here this is what I
wanted maybe g5 I don't know it's it's
it's it's really tricky I'm two pawns
down computer says equal equal equal
that you don't know he says this is
scary for me yeah I guess it is yeah I
just vote them that the computer gives
equal and I don't know what to make out
of it yeah okay this is this is a civil
line is is of course quite quite a risky
business c5 okay here I could have
played differently the computer wants to
go Bishop e3 yeah this is a less
committal way to do it but I didn't
think of that at this this looked very
dangerous to me nie Dage form yeah it
holds it simply it simply seems to hold
I had a comp now suggest this move
giving black an edge though yeah it's
tough it's tough it's it's it's with
chances but it's very very very tough to
play okay thanks for watching